this is Startalk this from John Huggins
John wants to know in preparing to go to
Mars are there or will there be a need
to be international treaties that
dictate the governance of Mars
if yes that would be that what would be
the key aspects of those treaties in
other words do we have a first of all
we've been on the moon so I'm sure
there's something that governs that not
solely yeah no not really well no so
governs it it says that you can't own
cosmic objects yeah so the inner space
the outer space treaty has provisions in
it that says this but the universe is a
frontier right and you can't own it you
can't there's no sovereign control over
it now at some point that's going to
have to change right because we have
Vladimir Putin and you go to Mars and
people start pitching their flag and
they build a home well you can't say
that no one owns the home I built the
damn home that's true so what is likely
or rather what is has been proposed okay
is that you put a homesteading kind of
rule in place all right the homesteading
is if you paid the money to get there
and you built your own damn house that's
your land so Bill Gates will be owning
Mars basically is what you just told me
just the rich from yes Bill Gates and
Richard brands well they try to do that
Richard mansion owns his own Island
right that's they kind of already do it
I already do that right but what it
means is on that island he hires
servants and gardeners and everything so
there's a business case for people to do
this right and why did the United States
promote homesteading to spread the
frontier and have the frontier and and
this is how you grow cities and
communities and so it will I'm thinking
it'll go that route because don't say
well earth we own all little patches of
this speck called Earth but the whole
universe no one owns it right I I don't
see that as the natural consequence of
human exploration or a human nature or
that's my feeling because the real deal
is from the time that we are little
teeny kids the first one of the first
words we say or sentences is that's mine
that's mine that's mine even when it's
not yours yours right and and and
especially in America what's the the one
of the first games we learn how to play
when we know how to play any good game
it's monopoly that's so true that who
wins the one who has all proper tickets
can't stop over until I win it all yes I
own everything and you have nothing
right
oh my god right talk about Tommy
celebrate this celebrate that and we say
wow you were good that is like the
height map ilysm yeah you crushed me I'm
a complete and utter popper now what I
was good when I was in graduate school
there was a fellow graduate student who
was from Russia right and I was
describing monopoly to him and when I
got to that point and the winner has all
the money and all the property and I
thought wow this is that this is like
before the Cold War ended right right
and it was like it was not playing well
in his no yes he was looking at you like
you capitalist beef that's yeah cuz
that's basically Wow
yeah I never looked at it that way but
that's it Wow we took my favorite
Monopoly joke it was by was the do's
names from Boston who's kind of surreal
Stephen right Stephen right yeah so he
said I'm I'm angry that only one company
makes the game Monopoly that's a picture
that's it isn't that good say that's a
good joke that's that I love the irony
of it this is Startalk